raus auf die straße darf er noch nicht
oli der erste autonom fahrende bus in
berlin
hindernisse erkennt ihr mit hilfe von
sensoren auf einem testgelände dreht er
bei drei monaten seiner wohnung ein bus
ohne fahrer so stellt sich der
verkehrsforscher weert canzler die
fahrzeuge der zukunft vor lernt
natürlich auch und das ist dann damit
verbunden dass man manchmal auch dann
ausfälle hat oder plötzlich bremst der
musst du noch lernen das ist ganz am
anfang ich meine so lange gibt etliche
und ist hochkomplex
schon in wenigen jahren sollen die
selbst fahrenden busse in der stadt
unterwegs sein und das ist erst der
anfang denn so könnte es auf den straßen
von morgen aussehen autonome mobile
aller art bringen uns selbstständig an
ziel und wir haben die wahl zwischen
vielen verschiedenen verkehrsmitteln
[Musik]
verknüpfung also einfach deutschland
sagte dass intermodalität als
verknüpfung verschiedener verkehrsmittel
und das private auto kann es nicht sein
das ist einfach völlig ineffizient das
private auto wird in der innenstadt
mittel und langfristig vermutlich ganz
die strafen sind schon jetzt voll in
berlin gibt es mehr als 12 millionen
private pkw und firmenautos und jedes
jahr kaum ein paar tausend dazu lärm
stau
schlechte luft da ruft legionäre mit
alternativen auf den plan
idee nummer eins das data clever shuttle
bietet zum beispiel ein modernes
sammeltaxi mit elektroantrieb per app
kann man sich einen wagen bestellen
auf einer individuell festgelegten route
werden dann weitere fahrgäste
mitgenommen
im grunde wie bei einem klassischen taxi
auch nur effizienter und günstiger
die idee dahinter ist dass man wege in
einer verbündet wenn zwei leute auf
ähnlichen wegen buchen macht es sinn sie
gemeinsam zu befördern weil es im
verkehrs reduzieren wirkt anstellt zwei
mal ein auto zu nehmen
nur eins und jede einzelne fahrgast
spart eine menge geld also wir
unterbieten taxipreise momentan um 50
prozent und in zukunft könnten die
sammeltaxis sogar teil des öffentlichen
nahverkehrs werden
sie fahren dann auf schienen doch
fahrpläne und feste haltestellen mittels
nicht sie werden per smartphone bestellt
und finden die weg von allein die zahl
der privaten fahrzeuge könnte in städten
also winden
dafür gibt es immer mehr carsharing
autos in berlin und schätzen experten
werden die sich in die nächsten 20
jahren mindestens verfünffacht haben
werden wir also auf unser eigenes auto
verzichten müssen
in einem autobegeisterten land wie
deutschland wird die mehrheit der bürger
erst einmal dagegen sein das weiß auch
diese berliner kiez initiative die autos
am liebsten abschaffen will
bis es soweit ist kann man mit ihrer app
getaway vorhandene pkw besser nutzen
wer sein auto nicht braucht der kann in
dieser zeit dem nachbarn zur verfügung
stellen
ich lasse mir eine technik einbauen
ganz einfach so gar keine klassischen
viele rom laufwerk und gestern dafür
dass über die app von gate array das
auto zu bedienen ist bezüglich dieser zu
öffnen ist wieder zu schließen ist und
die ganze abrechnung findet über die app
statt
und noch eine idee haben sie umgesetzt
stadt ein eigenes auto zu fahren kann
man auch ein lachten fahrrad mieten
natürlich mit elektroantrieb